FRED SAUER: So the App Engine
documentation is incomplete.
For example, the NDB docs, so
NDB is a Python library for
the data store, remain
minimal and early
document possible errors.
Anything you can do about this,
or is there other places
they should be looking?
MANDY WAITE: I guess really, one
of the standard answers to
this is to go to
Stack Overflow.
You're going to find
documentation--
you hear people talking about
things that are undocumented
or not so well documented,
providing examples and such
like in Stack Overflow.
Pretty much everything anybody
has tried to do is going to be
documented on Stack Overflow.
Things that have worked and
things that haven't worked.
So you can probably find
good answers there.
If you want to contribute
information as well, Stack
Overflow is not just for
questions, it's also for
sharing information as well.
So if you actually have some
useful information, so
something you've written
about, something you've
documented, you can share that
on Stock Overflow as well.
And that would be a good
place to put it.
And it also stops it from
being spread around
everywhere.
I mean we have multiple places
where people go to find
different documentations.
So that kind of ad-hoc
documentation is really
probably the best place
in Stack Overflow.
FRED SAUER: I think of the App
Engine core documentation as
the reference material,
the baseline.
Sometimes there is Javadoc or
Pydoc to the methods that may
help a little bit further.
But some of these--
like how do I use these
specifically?
Stack Overflow is a
great place to go.
And we do sometimes, if we find
that there's a lot of
questions around a particular
area in Stack Overflow, we do
go in and update the
documentation and maybe add
some clarification.
So that's definitely a
place to contribute.